do you know how insane it sounds to even  say that a cement provider landed a  six-figure contract from a tick-tock  how many people here are producing three  pieces of tick-tock video a day for  their business and if you raise your  hand i'm gonna check on stage publicly  so don't lie  i already have dozens of emails from  lawyers contractors a cement provider  hit me up last week that he landed a big  contract from a tick tick-tock do you  know how insane it sounds to even say  that a cement provider landed a  six-figure contract from a tick-tock  it's a reality are you challenging  yourself to do branding work because  branding is the singular thing that  grows anything it's just the way the  world works and so i think the  opportunity is extraordinary